[Musique]
dans le cadre des Journées européennes
du patrimoine qui auront lieu ces 16 et
17 septembre le musée historique de
Villèle a souhaité organiser une journée
pour les scolaires autour de
l'archéologie 10 classes de collégiens
ont pu profiter de divers ateliers
le but c'est que les élèves découvrent
ce que c'est que l'archéologie qu'on
informe aussi sur ce qu'on fait
actuellement au Musée parce qu'on est en
train de mener des fouilles
archéologiques préventives en vue de la
construction du nouveau musée donc les
élèves vont à la fois découvrir le
métier d'archéologue ce que l'on fait
quand on fait des phares des phases
d'archéologie sur un site historique et
peut-être va créer des vocations
un des ateliers phares de cette journée
une fouille en direct ou les jeunes ont
pu manipuler des outils d'archéologues
des objets anciens ont préalablement été
cachés les collégiens les ont fouillé
nettoyés puis inventorier c'est de la
terre cuite
c'est ce qu'on appelle de la terre cuite
architecturale ici plus précisément ce
sont des bouts de tuiles
donc des fragments de tuiles qui vont
permettre de nous dire que très
probablement ici par exemple peut-être
que le bâtiment était recouvert d'un
toit en tuile
comment est-ce qu'on fait la
calligraphie pour la retranscrire les
vieux
intéressant et là on est en train de
creuser pour découvrir comme
l'archéologue il cherche j'ai trouvé un
vieux morphine métal où il est clair je
sais pas trop
des ateliers créatifs ont également été
proposés comme la peinture sur verre ou
la fabrication de briques
j'interviens aujourd'hui auprès des
collégiens sur le thème de la brique la
brique a été un élément important pour
la fabrication des fours et qui ont été
transportés dans dans les bateaux
souvent dans le fond des bateaux pour
faire le leste des bateaux
[Musique]
et
après on va sculpter des trucs de filles
et intéressant puis c'est un peu
l'histoire de la Réunion et ça nous
apprend des vidéos
ça m'intéresse par rapport aux fruits
les trouvailles qui font et l'histoire
de la Réunion apparemment madame desbers
c'est amusant de fouiller de découvrir
de nouvelles choses en se cultivant les
collégiens ont enfin pu découvrir le
chantier des fouilles actuellement mené
au musée de Villèle avec les
explications de l'archéologue qui suit
le chantier
[Musique]